O
BY FAR, ATESHA T DOLLARS.
COMINGEVER SR --NKM GHHE REPUBLA
POWER OF THE PURSE,
'SON YOU
WHAT WTO THE RLI
THTHE  B LEADEN SIZEND
WITHT THISRT
TTS.I KNOW AND HEAT UP THAT S ON
UKLESS.
FOTHXTMEUPPORTREMAINRONG AND STT
IMPORTANT.
HOW WE A I GHTING READYMEI'
POSSIBLE NOT TWE
POLICATRENDSNT F I
SENDISE ENING UR SUPPORT O
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE ILL HELP XP.
THD TO KNOTHTOTHOSESW DONALD TR.
WECTINTERVIEWS H ABOUT
EVEN AFTER THEOF
HI HS
UNDETAND ABOUTIN?WHAT WILL YOU L
P HIM UNDERSTANDHEINSEE?>> T I E
ENGHY  TND WHOUTK T SUCHHIER NO
TT MS
OF YOUR OW
ALL
LIGENCDATA, TO
THN N YOU ED TO ROFILE,
IVINT  WILL MAKE TO
THA
THEDASION, DALTRUMP MENTIONE T
STD.
ONLYTHEVTH LOOK
THIS IS TH
TO.
VE HE  LOOK ATITIT WE
, TO SW Y E EDTHISS ST
L LETE DEOCCUP ANDWI TPRESID RUT
BECAUSE, AS YOU KN, LOTSF  BG AN
SANCTNLY.
nslator: NO.LIFT SANCTIONST USSI
WE CANNOT DISCUSS THE SUBSTANC
THUS.
AFTERWARDS, YEAH, WE CANRTLKING.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT RAK AB
DIALOGUE.
YES, WE CAN INVOLVE
IONSTSALOF
INVOLVINNSTHT AFTEE THAT'SE STT
UKRAINE, THE GOVERNMENT DOES
RELEASE THEM.
BUITS TENS OF THOUSA
lator: WE HAVER
OU GO TRENGTH.IA DOES HAVE A W
WE HAVE THIS HOMEFEND.WHERE NOW.
'SHY TN
HOW MUCH ME VICTIMS.